We're going to start with a conversation that I had with Jad a few weeks ago.
Okay. So I like medical stories.
This I know about you and this, you know, um,
and so I read this website called stat news.com which does sort of really,
it's like a new website out of Boston. It's new, right? They basically,
it's this collection of really amazing like medical reporters and I will click
on stories that look interesting and there was one about, um,
we'd just grown embryos, human embryos for a long time in a lab.
And that was when I read the phrase,
the 14 day rule for the first time.
And it was that apparently there's this thing that you can't grow an embryo in a
lab past 14 days. Huh.
Which I didn't even know you could grow an embryo in a lab at all. Right. Or,
or that people were or that, I mean,
I guess I knew IVF happened. Sure. Like test tube babies,
how long in the average IVF situation, how long has an embryo in a dish for it.
And then I realized, I didn't actually even know that either.
So then I just spun out.
So like the whole article is just interesting to me cause I was like,
uh,
I don't know about any of this, right?
I'm Molly Webster. Oh. And I am Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
And today on radio lab we're going to zip down a worm hole into another
universe. And Robert, you're coming with me. Okay.
W what can you tell me about the universe? [inaudible] okay,
you're going to want to buy a ticket because in this universe are twins and
souls and mice and something called the primitive streak and they're all
gathered together around a certain rule. And who am I making what the rule was?
Well, um, so you know how you can fertilize an egg,
you get negative sperm and you put them together. Yes. Fertilizes the egg,
right? And then the egg, the fertilized egg,
it multiplies multiply cell divides.
So a scientist could take it to watch it grow, to learn about human development,
but then they have to stop at day 14.
That's the rule because this is a medical kind of thing or science limitation.
It is, it's medical, it's all those things.
It's medical and it's science and there's like philosophy and ethics and
obviously religion and uh, that's, yeah, you're buying it now.
Bang. I have water. Okay, I'll take a sip. Okay.
And we are going to begin with this guy, Leroy Walters. Okay.
He was an ethicist at Georgetown University, now retired.
And to me he is sort of the father of the 14 day rule. I never,
I never thought of myself as the father 14 day rule,
but he is. He totally is. Well,
we shouldn't forget the context of 73 all right.
So 1973 Leroy has recently graduated with a doctorate in ethics from Yale
University and he's settling into his job and at the time,
medicine and ethics sort of collision course.
Yes, yes. [inaudible]
January, 1972
and landmark ruling the supreme court today legalized abortion.
Roe v Wade happens. It is clear,
at least under present law that a unborn fetus is not a person within the
meaning of the constitution. But just six months after that decision,
the issue of fetuses and research done with them.
Fetal research became a hot topic.
Some of the testimony in here is shocking news reports,
butchering and patting up in that area,
dissecting fetuses, even an instance of decapitating fetuses. Oh Man.
And then around the same time that human Guinea pig,
the research involving human beings,
controversial Tuskegee syphilis study news reports of the civil studies that
were done on African American men without their knowledge,
there was that sterilization of daughters had been sterilized without their
informed and women with intellectual disabilities,
extremis and genetic research, genetic engineering was coming into its own.
He have all these questions swirling about like how we feel about the human
body,
whether or not we want to experiment on and what do we protect and what don't we
protect.
It's just sort of this whirlwind and uh,
you are about to see a his time
then most relevant for our story.
Yeah. Okay. Is there in a sec,
on July 25th, 1978 scientists in the the,
okay. We are now in sizing the uterus itself
reduced
a child with the aid of invitro fertilization.
The first baby that was born from an embryo that was grown inside a tube.
Baby Lewis Brown babies.
No, that wasn't her eyes yet.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
Everyone in the world was fascinated,
but there were people who predicted doom.
What was the doom that in vitro fertilization would lead to reproduction as a
form of manufacturer.
So the government was grappling with,
we need more regulations or we need as a country to think about like what our
ethical guidelines are, right? So the Department of Health,
education and welfare,
and they put together something called the ethics advisory board panel of
doctors, layman academics,
even a Jesuit priest that's consider it some fundamental moral and ethical
questions. Questions involved in test tube, human fertilization.
It's meetings and discussions open today. Now as part of those meetings,
the board will call in these expert witnesses.
And one of those witnesses was our boy Leroy, right? The staff director.
And they asked Leroy like ethically,
tell us what we should be thinking about when it comes to embryos and how we are
to regard them.
And he says, well, there's a spectrum. And on the one side you could argue,
okay,
human embryos should be protected from the time of fertilization forward.
We shouldn't even be growing embryos in a lab at all.
But then there's the other side. Okay.
Most permissive position was that research could be done until about eight weeks
because
a fetus at about eight weeks can have a reflex response to a stimulus.
And then [inaudible]
at some point a committee member turns to Leroy and she says,
where would you draw the line? He pauses and he says, well,
well, I would say for me 14 days,
why 14? Well,
Leroy had a couple of different arguments for one before 14 days,
about 50% of early human embryos are simply sloughed off.
They're just sort of shed from the woman's uterus
and don't develop further.
So the thinking was, if we are already losing 50% of them, naturally
we don't have strong moral obligations toward early human embryos.
I see. You can even pose it as a metaphysical question.
If these are important beings, why do 50% of them disappear?
And we never had any knowledge of them. Argument number two,
early embryos can split into two
as in twin
or two. Separate embryos can recombine
into one embryo, right, like before 14 days in embryo,
doesn't know if it's one embryo or if it's like can be one person or if it's
going to be two people. So as Lee ripe put it,
it doesn't have a biological identity and that happens right around 14 days.
[inaudible] argument number three,
the primitive streak appears primitive streak.
The primitive streak is the first indication of a,
an access of the future body. People see it as like a,
the body starting to organize itself.
You might say it's the outline of the spinal cord that will develop later on.
It's the first hint of like shape.
All of those seem to kind of converge around 14 days.
Eventually the committee decides to Take Leroy's suggestion and recommend that
all research on human embryos be stopped at 14 days
with high expectations.
We submitted the report to Secretary of Health Education and welfare,
Joseph California on May 4th,
1979 and on July 19th,
1979 before he could respond,
secretary of California was fired by President Jimmy Carter.
It was part of a whole cabinet shakeup
and so the report has been sitting on shelves gathering dust and there has never
been a formal response.
It did end up becoming a guideline in the u s it's actually an international
guideline, but we never actually needed it because 14 days
that was so far beyond the capacity of researchers to culture early embryos that
it also seemed like a safe, a safe marker,
a safe boundary.
Because, and this is the interesting thing with IVF,
we're familiar with like days zero one two three four five,
six which is about the time they put the embryo into the mother [inaudible].
And so nobody had ever really seen how an embryo develops from day seven through
14 oh, interesting.
You can't photograph it through the body for like various reasons. For one,
no one ever knows they're pregnant that early. Like,
when did you and your wife realize you're pregnant?
It's like a month after the fertilization happens. Yeah. It's funny.
It's like when she, you, even if you're trying,
you don't actually know for weeks until, yeah.
And it's so small that even if you did know the way it attaches to the uterus,
it's sort of burrows in and you kinda can't see it. And at the same time,
scientists are pretty sure that this is a very important moment in development
and they just can't get to it. Wait, wait a second.
Life magazine 50 years ago published these gorgeous pictures of,
of a fertilized cell and then beautiful little baby with eyes,
you know, just, yeah. But the, the, the,
that they have pictures of sperms in eggs,
then there's a blank spot until at least three and a half weeks.
So that magazine spread. So we ha, so life didn't show the first few.
The second note there are no really? Yeah. You're saying it,
there is a place in the development of the human being that no scientist has
seen. No ever. No. Really. Yeah.
So this is this kind of period, which in the textbook who would find,
describe as a black box,
which brings us to Magdalena though I Magdala [inaudible] met the University of
Cambridge in UK. Okay, great. Thank you.
She for years had been trying to figure out how to grow embryos during this
period,
but for those experiments and the problem was at this point the embryo is
beginning to attach to the mother's uterus and so just need certain things from
the mother and if you try and grow it in a dish,
it just shrivels up and dies. Yes, yes. So at the time we were trying create,
scratch our heads and come up with demos and enriching environment.
We could imagine like maybe I can like recreate that really warm,
cozy home, but in a dish without the mom.
Interesting.
So it's like experimenting like what is the right a bath that the growing embryo
needs to sort of get what it needs.
And they decided that while they were still trying to figure it out,
they would just do it on mice embryos first.
And so she started essentially just, um,
coming up with like chemistry concoctions.
They started with the Gel,
which was a particular LSD CT sort of gloppy and Gooey,
and then they toss it a siro made from human placentas,
added some hormones like progesterone along with five ProPlus growth factors.
And of course the Dasho slamming in fiboronectin is sounds like it.
Like someone would sell this as like a face cream or something.
They even tried serum from, that's Placentas. That actually really didn't work.
It was not so good as this. You don't from the human person say yes, you know,
so for five years they put stuff in, they pulled stuff out,
they tried everything until they ended up with something that at least on mice
seem to work really well. So they thought, okay,
maybe it's time we try this with human embryos. We took two,
Andrew's just two human blastocyst,
put them in a dish with their chemical concoction and an amazing grip.
It works.
One of them ditch make it to 13 days.
The other one didn't, but one made it right.
Suddenly they had an embryo that was growing happily into day eight,
day nine, day 10
and they were able to see all of these moments in human development that no one
had ever seen before.
And, and guess what Robert? Yeah, I got to see them too. I did.
We want to come. Of course. I want to come. Okay. Alicia, go right now.
I mean we are going to go but we're going to actually have to take a break
first. Oh God. So we'll be back in a bit. Okay.
Hi, this is Lizzie from Arlington, Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
when the legendary rapper prodigy died after being hospitalized for sickle cell
anemia last year. His friends, his fans were shocked in the summertime.
Tony know you talking about this sunny day right here that we have right now,
man making beats Friday g is dead, right man.
I'm Mary Harris and I'm Christopher Johnson.
The realness is a new podcast from w NYC studios.
It takes you inside prodigy's music and asks why he couldn't escape a single
recessive gene.
Listen and subscribe to the realness wherever you get your podcasts.
Okay, we're back. I am Robert Krulwich.
I'm Molly Webster is Radiolab and today the 14 day rule.
Last we left you.
We had just met a woman who managed to grow a human embryo in a lab right up to
the 14 day line. Now we get to see it, right? That's your promise. Yes.
When your phone on one of your phone off. Good look. Good luck.
Lucky enough for me
in embryology lab right here in New York, Rockefeller University.
How are you? Nice to meet you. Run by this guy, radio scientists,
Ali Ribbon. Lou. I fake being a scientist,
but Ali's team building off of Magdalena's work.
They were also growing human embryos in the lab to the 14 day mark,
so we invited me up to see them
or are seeing something that no other human beings has ever seen except the
group in this lab and Obviously Magda lab way.
How many people are in this lab that you think saw?
Let's see what a total of 25 so then I'll be like 26 so Ali has to step out of
the room. I'm excited. Thank you Ali. And he passes me off to a,
the guy that runs like the human embryology research,
the lab and a lab technician. She, she up in Nigrini to Chile.
Up Pellegrino? Yes. Okay. We go into the lab, walk into the call lab.
It's very big and everyone's looking at plots of benches and microscopes and
people pipetting. And so a fridge,
there's a little sticky note on the fridge that says experiment 27 embryos here.
So we keep them Tipa and Shelia
pulls out like a plastic box that has a blue bottom and like a white opaque top.
The Lid just came off and inside there was kind of like a microscope slide and
the embryos were attached to that, but there's condensation on it.
So we had to wait like 10 minutes. I got weirdly nervous,
but eventually we'll be like,
look down into this like little square. Well. Okay.
It's like 10 millimeters by 10 millimeters and it has a little bit of liquid in
it. And then inside that liquid,
yeah.
Wow. This is human embryo. How big is it? How big is the embryo?
You talk about 14 days, and in my mind I do imagine a tiny little human.
Is it even [inaudible]
human like at that point, tiny dot right there. No is just the little white dot.
Really crapped. It's really small. That's like a grain of sand.
It's about that size
and it looks like I'm,
I kept also thinking that it looked like if you took a sheet of typing paper and
you took a pin and you poked a hole in the paper and a little pinpoint of light
came through, it looks like that.
Oh,
I cannot believe that goes into a five foot nine tall human being.
So that was a day 12 embryo we were looking at with our naked eye,
but guest and Tutelian also took me over to this badass microscope.
I don't want to break anything.
So we could look at a bunch of images and see the development of an embryo day
by day. Starting with day eight. You see right here, like he,
you have the embryo mass. What are you, what does it look like? It's uh,
it looks very lunar to me blown out gray sphere that has like modeled surfaces,
but inside of it are hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of cells.
[inaudible] primitive endoderm and there's Abby glass,
there were like three different types of cells.
But to me it like looked like a simple structure.
And then this is the same embryo the next day. Wait is this day nine? Oh whoa.
It looks totally different. So it starts to get a little more complex.
Now we can see nuclei that what all those bright spots are. Yeah,
there's a nucleus, there's a nucleus, huh? And it can we switch from nine to 10.
So what are those little oil drop up looking?
Things like oil droplets don't date.
So now there are these like spiritual balls around the edges and it could be any
number of things, but guess things. They might be fat, like Lipid.
And the embryo, it starts forming like the asymmetry,
like you see things move to different areas of the south makes a hollow shell
inside.
And then your inner gut cavity that starts to form and there's all of a sudden a
new cell type. We've never seen the yolk sac trove ectoderm cells.
So a totally new type of cell. No one's ever seen before.
So we don't know where it comes from and neither does anyone else.
And then day 11 do I get excited every time you open one of them.
Okay. Day 11
okay.
Day 11 didn't really like, looks at different to me.
Date Day 12 day 12 has a lot more going on. That's the origin of the placenta.
Cool.
Day 13 there's all this brightness at the bottom in the upper left hand corner.
These could be at the last house. Okay.
Remind me again the eblast is that is the the cell type from which the entire
body eventually marches.
Guess says those are the cells that all of the body comes from.
Like all the other stuff is mostly just support. Oh Wow. So it's like the,
it's like the primal, like primordial foundational cells. Yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so I actually got there on day 13 of the experiments so all of the embryos were
just sort of waiting to get to day 14 and so that was it.
So let's shut this down and get this guy back in the incubator and then I was
just sort of spit back out into the real world.
Are they learning fantastically new, amazing things based on this or this one?
Like the,
the big takeaway that both of the groups had was that this embryo grew for
another week without any maternal input and it grew basically as it should have
grown,
which was mind blowing to me and to all of my colleagues that the human embryo
will behave in a self organizing manner in a complete absence of maternal inputs
at least for 14 days.
I think they always thought even if they got the chemistry right,
there'd be some sort of system breakdown because it wasn't getting input from
the mom. Interesting.
I always like keep thinking of it as like the anti mother's Day message.
The embryo
doesn't need you happy mother's Day.
Um, but the, the one pro pro mom thing is by the,
by the end in between day like 12 to 14,
it became clear that it started needing maternal input. I see.
And so do they know well so they don't I this is a party that was cool.
It was like, um,
they saw that the embryo started forming tunnels and pathways for the mom to
like infiltrate.
So there were little tubes and pathways of forum where like nerve attachment
could happen and like circulation.
So it prepares itself in this week for the mom and the connection.
Really cool.
It's like [inaudible] it's like hooking itself up to the network in a way.
I know. It's funny. It's like coming online as like a human being. Yeah,
that's a good way to put it. Yeah. That's cool.
The other cool thing was a guest told me that right around day 10 along the
edges of the embryo, this hormone shows up and that your body had,
doesn't have before. It's called like a Ganache, a trophon. So you know,
when you take a pregnancy test, hmm. The thing it's reading is that hormone.
Oh it is that he thinks like the embryo broadcasting. Yes.
It's like
boom, boom, boom
out to the rest of the body. Like I'm here, I'm here. Look at this hormone. Wow,
that's super cool.
What is it like to look through a microscope and see day eight when we've been
stopped at day seven since the 1970s or day nine or take 10
it's hard to describe it.
When people receive the digital image of the Hubble telescope,
those first few eyes who are getting it in their screens,
I guess it has to be something very similar to that.
When I look inside of our own,
and that's to me at the time where nobody knows that we even exist is the same
as looking at dimensions that would have never imagined would ever see because
we didn't even know they exist
[inaudible]
but then at day 14 you have to essentially bomb it. Huh?
You like um, can make it stop growing and freeze in the place that it's at.
They call it fixing, but if they want it to, what could they go past 14 days?
Maybe, but Ali,
he said that as they got closer to day 14 they noticed changes in the embryo.
That made it clear that it started needing more than just the current bath that
it was in. Okay. But like in Britain, Lou says this too, in Magdalena says,
this is like every day feels like an accomplishment. You're like, oh my gosh,
it grew another day. And then you start like cheering it on. You're like
another day grow another day. Oh my gosh. And it becomes
like, you're like championing it it and then you're like, okay,
stop. You're done. Right. And I felt like when I was standing there I was like,
oh, that's abrupt because I wanted it to grow,
grow, grow, grow, grow. But obviously I don't want it to grow, grow,
grow too far. So I was like, good,
are they 1516 and then I'm like, when does the joy in my voice stuff,
I eventually, I'm going to hit him. Don't worry.
I'm going to hit a point where I'm like, that's uncomfortable. Right?
This is something that touches us in the root of our own definition of our being
in existence. In individuality,
it's becomes a little bit like a Pandora box. So yes,
you to open it, but you have to be ready to see what's in it.
If technology has now moved it a whole nother week, so we can go for 14 days,
maybe it's pretty soon, you can go a whole nother week. And then home mother,
we got what are the, what does that mean? The rules going to have to change?
That is the conversation that's happening right now. Um,
basically once this research was published,
there were commentaries and articles and columns about what do we do about the
14 day rule? And there's conferences,
there's a conference in Boston that's happening in the fall.
Well, what are your choices though? Like you could choose,
could, could do any number of things.
It depends on where you sort of throw down a biological or moral marker that you
feel comfortable with. Like, um,
you could keep it at 14 days and sort of keep it around like this idea of
twinning and the primitive streak. Uh, you could move it a week out.
So say today,
21 when there's interesting sort of neural folds and divisions that are starting
to happen in the brain, you could go to eight weeks,
but it could also go back to zero. Oh, so there's no consensus on, no, no.
There's no consensus. And the scientists are the first to say like,
they don't want to make this decision. They just think like,
maybe we should have this conversation as a group. Um,
so this society decides not us. So yeah. And then, but it's just like,
if you say that like, it's amazing as like the Hubble telescope.
How does it feel when you're like,
I've gotten this far and now I have to end it?
Um, so that's the toughest question you're gonna ask me today. Uh,
for me,
for sure it was important to stop the experiments where there was still a
message that we could convey that would not offend people.
This is more than just science.
One of the greatest challenge in reproductive biology,
especially in human reproductive biology,
is to make sure that you don't offend people sense of uh,
identity, dignity, religion.
And so Ali,
he finds himself trying to keep all of these different perspectives in his head
all once.
So for example, if the Catholic point of view is human religions conception,
then I have to respect also the Jewish point of view that says, you know,
what is that heartbeat?
Also have to respect the Muslim point of view about the origin of human life,
which surprisingly for Ron seems to be similar than the Jewish point of view is
also heartbeats. I also have to respect the Buddhist point of view.
And what about the Hindus? The Buddhist says if you don't get [inaudible],
you're not independent, you're not a human being.
You don't call an organic human being as it's attached to you. And Hindu says,
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
There is no origin or and what circles within circles within circles.
I'm a butterfly today I'm going to die and come back as a tiger.
I'm going to then come back as a human, then come back as an elephant.
What origin? That circle does not have an origin.
So I am for the progress of silence.
I am for gaining knowledge. It's my job.
It's the way I'm wired as a human being.
I satisfy our sense of curiosity and there's nothing more curious to me than our
own region.
So then that would be like you would love to know like what happens on day 21
absolutely. And I like to think that before I die,
we will know what happens on day 21
this episode was produced by Annie Mcewen with help from Matt Kielty and Brennan
Pharell and Simon Adler. I actually think the entire radio lab staff.
It's something to do with this episode. So thanks guys.
And I want to thank the research library at Georgetown University.
Thank you for listening. See you later.